kürzlich hat man einen Freund für seine
Big Five verzählt
und was eigentlich die Idee ist von dem
eine sehr sich überlegen
aber funktioniert das wirklich darüber
reden
[Musik]
das war das Gute und das schöne
bestimmt ja nein also ich glaube so
Erkenntnis auch Neugier bis Wellen
und zweite wäre das Gute das ist
Gerechtigkeit
solidaritätshilfe darüber nachdenken
sehr desto besser und das ist natürlich
die Theorie von deine Big Five das ist
relativ also die Idee the Big Five for
Life Messer
und wenn wir durch hinreichend konkret
bestimmt haben
einiges drunter verstorben und in dem
Roman Gott eigentlich darum dass so ein
sterbenskranken super erfolgreicher
Thomas der geht in eine andere Figur
also wie klingt eigentlich
Grundidee und lustige schöne
ursprünglich das sind
riesenviert
wenn man oft
Safari der Leopard was ist das Elefant
und
platzhaft Reis
aber nicht zu abstrakten
finden
das Problem
total will ich auch ganz generell finde
die Idee von dem live-planing dass du
dich planen dass du es in Plan machst
das werde ich erreichen dass ich
irgendwie irritieren will danke die
große wichtige Sache sind aber
tatsächlich gewonnen nicht abhaken
für mich ist extrem wichtig klingen die
Beziehungen Freundschaften Familie
überhaupt
und all diese Sachen
zwingen du hast dich aber dafür öffnen
und ich glaube das werden
aber den kannst du sagen ein Ziel ist
Freundschaften Zahl also sehe ich dem
auch rumgame im Leben
es braucht extrem viel Disziplin
paradoxe das Leben
schon wichtig bestimmt
aber ist so mega wichtig Party machen
ins Kino gehen
und dann wird Vater und plötzlich ist
Baby die heißt grosse Kino durch dich
verändert das Vater ich habe auch hinten
wäre ich bin und was mir wichtig ist
und jetzt Status im Moment aufschreiben
in der nächsten 50 Jahre wichtig ist
sondern man muss offen bleiben für
identitätswandeln aber
es ist eigentlich das Wort
transformativ erfahren
sogar die Idee vom planen der Vorgang
und vor dem rationalen Entscheider ist
ein Stück weit
du dich rational entscheidet zwischen
zwei Optionen wenn du nicht weißt wie du
sie wärst wenn du das den Entschädigung
genau wie du denn mehr siehst
Sprung oder Kirche
Risikos vertrauen aber das lustig
interessant
ist klar
unten in die Kommentaren sind gespannt
ein vorschlagen was eigentlich wirklich
die Idee dass man das überlegen die
ich finde es super pur und der ganze
wichtigste Gedanke Experiment sie jetzt
durch wirklich gemacht aber mir alles
vorstellbar
und ich finde das verortet das macht es
bewusst wir sind sterblich und was User
gefunden hat ist eigentlich ein Konsens
also viele bereue geschafft
sich selber
natürlich sagen
wieso Hanni nur so viel geschafft hat
dich nur mir mit Knopf aber jetzt
überlegte doch mal umgekehrt wie viel
Frauen wo sich immer nur um Kind kümmern
kann wahrscheinlich
so dass man einfach das bereut wohl
nicht so viel Platz gehabt
hätte so
ich glaube dass es sich eine Tendenz zu
dem und dazu institutionelle
hintergrundbedingungen
ich bereue wahnsinnig dass sie so viel
geschafft hat hat die doch nur weltreis
gemacht da muss man zum Weltreise machen
erst mal auch ziemlich viel Geld da ohne
schaffe Gott nicht natürlich also wie
lange lebst du also wenn ich jetzt schon
meine wichtigsten Sachen machen und
zeige ich schaffe jetzt nur 20 %. und
ich investiere alles mit der alten
Weg und da komme ich zurück und dann ist
Problem oder also wenn machst dir Sachen
oder wie du sie dosieren auf dieser
Arbeit das ist sicherer Punkt mit
Absicht zu tun für Verfügbarkeit von
Totten passiert aber ich finde ich finde
es total
Strategie finden die dich interessant
aber sie haben ihre Problem
möglich sind wir bereuen bis also ihr
interessanter ist immer Interessen der
Hand je mehr Möglichkeiten der Hand
desto größer Johnson
ja das weiß ich nicht das weiß ich nicht
du bist doch bewusst dass du nie alles
falsch machen
ja und trotzdem es ist völlig normal
dass du irgendwo durch betonend die
andere vier Optionen
und das ist ganz
nix Gefühl
und das gehört zum menschlichen Leben
Normalfall ja aber ich glaube
die ist nicht oder bist du wirklich
besser sagen
dazu gehört das ist gab ganz wichtig ist
und wenn du immer Angst hast
du wunderbare romanin sind die
Glasglocke muss
beschreibt was ich nicht entscheiden und
sie beschreibt dir das Leben als würde
sie immer fieberbaum sitzen Umgehen von
purpurroten Reifen Feigen schreibt sie
und sie sitzt der arschkabel nicht und
sie verhungerte den Baum inneren
sondern du musst irgendwie konzentrieren
und dann hätte nicht alles Platz ja und
alles ist
entscheidend
oder du hast dich nicht aus der
verantwortlich erstellen das ist glaube
schon ein wichtiger Punkt aber ich weiß
nicht oder richtig Begriffe
mit Angst
verpassen das ist natürlich jeder Multi
optionsgesellschaften Normalzustand
[Musik]
umso interessanter
je mehr Sehnsucht er oder sie hätte das
großartigen Menschen dass man viel
Interesse an und darum gehört
zeigen ich bin endlich endlich
die negative Gefühl das Problem ist
etwas wirklich Zeit im Leben sondern
immer zu dem Vordringen wo wirklich Zeit
also wir müssen abhaken
können oder was ist wirklich so wichtig
Motivation
ja genau
schwierig also es geht einfach so
Gedankenexperiment und anderen ist
glaube ja was denn oft passiert sind so
Schicksalsschläge bis was passiert im
Leben Todesfall vielleicht in der
Familie oder ein guter Freund ein
Krankheiten
nennt das Grenzsituationen und die sind
ganz wichtig wie die werfen neues was
anderes klares Licht aufs Ganze Lebens
verstanden
für mich ist Challenge noch hat die
Haltung können es bewahrungsmittel das
finde ich total schwierig
soziologischer mal aber das letzte ich
hätte verzählt was in einem Erfahrung
mit den Herzinfarkt und etwas Nachruf
auf mich selbst
was das heißt und er seit dem Grund ich
habe jeden die Übung für sich machen
auch wenn die Erfahrung mit wirklich
selber machst sondern du hast ja
überlegen was soll im Nachruf starten
sondern was für eine Person bist du sie
dass man auch
das ist aber sozusagen Mensch
Wetter sie oder als was wird er gesagt
für das deutsche Philosophen
Exposition also setzt dich an deine
Angst
auf der Straße
einfach mal und ich glaube das ist der
wieder das erleben wir sind gleich halt
Menschen
dir wo Sachen
können eigentlich hilft es
Gedankenexperimente eben nicht sondern
wenn zwei bis drei ist passiert du bist
kaputt und es ist scheiße Punkt oder ähm
einfach mega schwierig ich finde
und ich finde gerade das Philosophie
Philosophie nicht wissen so viel über
Theorie von dabei und gleich am Ende vom
Tag kämpfen Rolle mit der gleichen Sache
und das ist nicht so einfach zu rechts
vom Leben was sagen
eigentlich schon mega viel erlaubt und
mega viel erreicht von der Moni hawelle
und jetzt ist der Schock sie und so das
Gefühl
[Musik]
oder
direkt
Wunsch wenn man erfüllt hat
so eine Lehre zurück und dann braucht
man eine neue Wunsch was ich heute
irgendwie einem abtreibt und die Themen
finde ich interessant sich überlegen
also nicht nur so der horizontale übrig
die Ahnung was ich mit Lebensplan
sondern der vertikal Überprüfung
also sich immer wieder für jede einzelne
Moment schon durch den fast ich hoffe
ich der buddhistische issicht auch
interessant befindet wieder Sofa und den
plötzlich
meditationsblatt
im Einzelnen Augenblick ich glaube es
braucht beides einerseits
aber auch die große Ganze